I am someone who wakes up in a different
body every day always someone my age but
never too far in the last never the same
person twice and I have absolutely no
control over any of it
the day that Amy shadowed you at school
I was Amy in the day that he went to the
beach with Justin I was Justin it's not
possible it is hey it's me every day of
your life you've just woken up and just
try to live that day before that person
that sounds really lonely it isn't
because I know what makes each person
different and what makes everyone the
same why are you doing this day we met I
hope something I've never felt before I
don't want to let that go I am so proud
oh thank you
I'm in love with someone who wakes up in
a different body every day always the
same age never the same person twice for
such a bright beautiful kind funny
person tomorrow wake up as a kid who's
not flying back here oh my god this kids
is not exercise
you
whoever was that I'm forcing Alexander
out of his own life that's wrong what
are you saying
think about what happens if you and I
stay together we can make it work
I want to believe that
what will happen to your life if I'm the
person in the world that you're closest
to
what about uh you know I thought you
left left I never leave do them every
day